it hasn't been easy getting hold of a
much needed bottle of penicillin so this
is your medicine to make you feel better
Lexi has been hit with scarlet fever her
mom spent most of the day searching for
pharmacies which had the medicine in
stock I got told by the GP and also by
the pharmacy that it we might struggle
wasn't offered any alternatives so I
phoned around a few pharmacies once I
got it and was luckily was a the third
one I called had it in stock it's just
frustrating it they should it with this
going on there needs to be more
available
at Lexi's school there's been an
outbreak of the contagious infection
which is caused by the bacteria that can
lead to invasive group a strep one child
here has been diagnosed with it whilst
attendance has dropped to record lows
the trust which runs five primary
schools have brought in covid-19 type
measures whilst they wait for public
health advice and guidance it's
certainly worrying when you know we are
looking at having outbreaks in three of
our schools that actually there could be
an answer to that
um to to stop the spread and to to help
those pupils
um but actually it might not be
available and at the school Gates
parents were Keen to share their
concerns all sure today shortages at the
moment it's scary it's like you know
about bringing your children in or do
you not or it's it's worrying even
though the pharmacist saying that
they're sure that is very concerning
with the Prime Minister today with
reassurances about the supply of drugs
and the continuing spread of strep a
there are no current shortages of drugs
available to treat this in their
well-established procedures in place to
ensure that that remains at the case but
chemists up and down the country told
Sky News they are running short if there
is decent supply of stock
um pharmacies are not getting them
um every time they go online to order
from their wholesaler and Redline comes
up saying it's out of stock
scarlet fever isn't uncommon for this
time of year but the level at which
children are being infected is for those
eventually needing antibiotics there is
on ease but pharmaceutical companies say
there isn't a manufacturing issue making
it hard to pinpoint where the problem
lies inzaman Rashid Sky News in crew